SIX GAMES.
CANADIENS JUST 7, 23 AND 4.
THEY HAVE NO, START THE
GAME FOR BOSTON.
UP MINUTE-AND-A-HALF
GONE BY HERE IN BOSTON.
BACK OUTICK OF  THE SHOT
THROUG
FOR BOSTON.
BACK OUT TO McAVOY.
McAVAV PASTRNAK.
HE BLASTS IT OFF THET GRZELCYK'.
AVOIDS THE DEFENDER, STOPS IN
THE CREASE AREA,.
BACK OUT.
SMITH, FIRED, DEFLECTED HERE.
THREE DIFFERENT PLAYERS TRYING
TO GET IT.
IT'SGRZELCYK.
DeBRUSK K
HERE'S THE SHOT FROM DeBRUSK AND
RIGHT THERE OFF TH 3-0.
TWO GOALS IN 15 SECOND
SKATE?
JONATHAN DROUIN.S LIAM
>> DROUIN LEADING INTO THAT ONE,
GOT .
HERE COMES BERGERON RON MOORE
WITH THE SHOT.HUSTLE.S MARCHAND
AROUND.
>> BROUGHT BY KULAC, THROUGH, ST
AND FIRES IT.
THE CANADIENS FOURTHY CHIAROT W
STICK.
THE DADIENCE PULE MARCHAND SHOR
cHABEE.
NOW SHE'
FOLLOWED BE THE  BO.
IT'S LAZAR AGAIN PROVIDING THA .
PUCK COMES OUT IN FRONT.
SOR HALL A. GREAT
JOB DRIVING TH THE STREAK, THET
BIG PART OF ITDUAL PERFORMANCE
CURTIS LAZAR, LOOKING